the anima the woman within difficult and
subtle ethical problems are not
invariably brought up by the appearance
of the shadow itself often another inner
figure emerges if the dreamer is a man
he will discover a female
personification of his unconscious and
it will be a male figure in the case of
a woman often this second symbolic
figure turns up behind the shadow
bringing up new and different problems
young called it's male and female forms
animus and anima the anima is a
personification of all feminine
psychological tendencies in a man's
psyche such as vague feelings and moods
prophetic hunches receptiveness to the
irrational capacity for personal love
feeling for nature and last but not
least his relation to the unconscious it
is no mere chance that in olden times
priestesses like the Greeks Sibyl were
used to fathom the Divine Will and to
make connection with the gods a
particularly good example of how the
anima is experienced as an inner figure
and a man psyche is found in the
medicine men and prophets shamans among
the Eskimo and other arctic tribes some
of these even wear women's clothes or
have breasts depicted on their garments
in order to manifest their inner
feminine side the side that enables them
to connect with the ghost land that is
what we call the unconscious one
reported case tells of a young man who
was being initiated by an older shaman
and who was buried by him in a snow hole
he fell into a state of dreaminess and
exhaustion in this coma he suddenly saw
a woman who emitted light she instructed
him in all he needed to know and later
as his protective spirit helped him to
practice his difficult profession by
relating him to the powers of the beyond
such an experience shows the anima as
the personification of a man's
unconscious in its individual
manifestation the character of a man's
anima is as a rule shaped by his mother
if he feels that his mother had a
negative
influence on him his animal will often
express itself in irritable depressed
moods uncertainty insecurity and
touchiness if however he is able to
overcome the negative assaults on
himself they can even serve to reinforce
his masculinity within the soul of such
a man the negative mother anima figure
will endlessly repeat this theme I am
nothing nothing makes any sense with
others it's different but for me I enjoy
noting these animal moods cause a sort
of dullness a fear of disease of
impotence or of accidents the whole of
life takes on a sad and depressive
aspect such dark moods can even lure a
man to suicide in which case the anima
becomes a death demon she appears in
this role in Cocteau's film or Fay the
French call such an animal figure a faun
fatale a milder version of this dark
anima is personified by the queen of the
night in Mozart's Magic Flute the Greek
sirens or the German Lorelei also
personified this dangerous aspect of the
anima which in this form symbolizes
destructive illusion the following
Siberian tale illustrates the behavior
of such a destructive anima one day a
lonely hunter sees a beautiful woman
emerging from the deep forest on the
other side of the river she waves at him
and sings oh come lonely hunter in the
stillness of dusk
come come I miss you I miss you now I
will embrace you embrace you come come
my nest is near my nest is near
come come lonely hunter now in the
stillness of dusk he throws off his
clothes and swims across the river but
suddenly she flies away in the form of
an owl laughing mockingly at him when he
tries to swim back to find his clothes
he drowns in the cold river in this tale
the anima symbolizes an unreal dream of
love happiness and maternal warmth her
nest a dream that lures men away from
reality the hunter is drowned because he
ran after a wishful fantasy that could
not
fulfill another way in which the
negative anima in a man's personality
can be revealed is in waspish poisonous
effeminate remarks by which he did al
use everything remarks of this sort
always contain a cheap twisting of the
truth and are in a subtle way
destructive there are legends throughout
the world in which a poisoned damsel as
they call her in the Orient appears she
is a beautiful creature who has weapons
hidden in her body or a secret poison
with which she kills her lover's during
our first night together in this guise
the anima is as cold and reckless as
certain uncanny aspects of nature itself
and in Europe is often expressed to this
day by the belief in witches if on the
other hand a man's experience of his
mother has been positive this can also
affect his anima in typical but
different ways with the result that he
either becomes a feminist or is preyed
upon by women and thus is unable to cope
with the hardships of life an anima of
this sort can turn men into
sentimentalists or they may become as
touchy as old maids or as sensitive as
the fairy tale princess who could feel a
pea under 30 mattresses a still more
subtle manifestation of a negative anima
appears in some fairy tale in the form
of a princess who asks her suitors to
answer a series of riddles or perhaps to
hide themselves under her nose if they
cannot give the answers or if she can
find them they must die and she
invariably wind the anima in this guise
involved men in a destructive
intellectual game we can notice the
effect of this anima trick in all those
neurotic pseudo-intellectual dialogues
that inhibit a man from getting into
direct touch with life and it's real
decisions he reflects about life so much
that he cannot live it and loses all his
spontaneity and outgoing feeling the
most frequent manifestation of the anima
takes the form of erotic fantasy men may
be driven to nurse their fantasies by
looking at films and striptease shows or
by daydreaming over pornographic
material this is a crude primitive
aspect of the anima which becomes
compulsive only
man does not sufficiently cultivate his
feeling relationships when his feeling
attitude toward life has remained
infantile all these aspects of the anima
have the same tendency that we have
observed in the shadow that is they can
be projected so that they appear to the
man to be the qualities of some
particular woman it is the presence of
the anima that causes a man to fall
suddenly in love when he sees a woman
for the first time and knows at once
that this is she in this situation the
man feels as if he has known this woman
intimately for all time he falls for her
so helplessly that it looks to outsiders
like complete madness women who are a
fairy like character especially attract
such animal projections because men can
attribute almost anything to a creature
who is so fascinatingly vague and can
thus proceed to weave fantasies around
her the projection of the anima in such
a sudden and passionate form as a love
affair can greatly disturb a man's
marriage and can lead to the so-called
human triangle with its accompanying
difficulties a bearable solution to such
a drama can be found only if the anima
is recognized as an inner power
the secret aim of the unconscious in
bringing about such an entanglement is
to force a man to develop and to bring
his own being to maturity by integrating
more of his unconscious personality and
bringing it into his real life but I
have said enough about the negative side
of the animal there are just as many
important positive aspects the anima is
for instance responsible for the fact
that a man is able to find the right
marriage partner another function is at
least equally important whenever a man's
logical mind is incapable of discerning
facts that are hidden in his unconscious
the anima helps him to dig them up even
more vital is the role that the anima
plays in putting a man's mind in tune
with the right inner values and thereby
opening the way into more profound inner
depths it is as if an inner radio
becomes tuned to a certain wavelength
that excludes your relevancies but
allows the voice of the great man to be
heard in establishing this inner radio
reception the anima takes on the role of
guide or mediator to the world within
and to the self that is how she appears
in the example of the initiations of
shamans that I described earlier this is
the role of Beth Ricci and Dante's
Paradiso
and also of the goddess Isis when she
appeared in a dream to oculus the famous
author of the Golden Ass in order to
initiate him into a higher more
spiritual form of life the dream of a 45
year old psychotherapist may help to
make clear how the anima can be an inner
guide as he was going to bed on the
evening before he had this dream he
thought to himself that it was hard to
stand alone in life lacking the support
of a church he found himself envying
people who are protected by the maternal
embrace of an organization he had been
born a Protestant but no longer had any
religious affiliation this was his dream
I am in the aisle of an old church
filled with people together with my
mother and my wife I sit at the end of
the aisle in what seemed to be extra
seats I am to celebrate the mass as a
priest and I have a big mass book in my
hands or rather a prayer book or an
anthology of poems this book is not
familiar to me and I cannot find the
right text I am very excited because I
have to begin soon and to add to my
troubles my mother and wife disturbed me
by chattering about unimportant trifles
now the organ stops and everybody is
waiting for me so I get up in a
determined way and ask one of the nuns
who is kneeling behind me to hand me her
mass book and point out the right place
which she does in an obliging manner now
like a sort of sexton this same nun
precedes me to the altar which is
somewhere behind me and to the left as
if we are approaching it from a side
aisle the mass book is like a sheet of
pictures a sort of board three feet long
and the foot wide and on it is the text
with ancient pictures in columns one
beside the other first the nun has to
read a part of the liturgy before I
begin
and I have still not found the right
place in the text she has told me that
it is number 15 but the numbers are not
clear and I cannot find it with
determination however I turned toward
the congregation and now I have found
number 15 the next-to-the-last on the
board
although I do not yet know if I shall be
able to decipher it
I want to try all the same I wake up
this dream expressed in a symbolic way
an answer from the unconscious to the
thoughts that the dreamer had had the
evening before it said to him in effect
you yourself must become a priest in
your own inner church in the Church of
your soul thus the dream shows that the
dreamer does have the helpful support of
an organization he is contained in a
church not an external church but one
that exists inside his own soul the
people all his own psychic qualities
want him to function as the priest and
celebrate the mass himself now the dream
cannot mean the actual mass for its mass
book is very different from the real one
it seems that the idea of the mass is
used as a symbol and therefore it means
a sacrificial act in which the divinity
is present so that man can communicate
with it this symbolic solution is of
course not generally valid but relates
to this particular dreamer it is a
typical solution for a Protestant
because a man who through real faith is
still contained in the Catholic Church
usually experiences his anima in the
image of the church herself and her
sacred images are for him
the symbols of the unconscious our
dreamer did not have this ecclesiastical
experience and this is why he had to
follow an inner way furthermore the
dream told him what he should do had
said your mother boundness and your
extraversion represented by the wife who
is an extrovert distract you and make
you feel insecure and by meaningless
talk keep you from celebrating the inner
mass but if you follow the nun the
introverted anima she will lead you as
both a servant and a priest
she owns a strange mass book which is
composed of 16 4 times four ancient
picture
your mask consists of your contemplation
of these psychic images that your
religious anima reveals to you in other
words if the dreamer overcomes his inner
uncertainty caused by his mother complex
he will find that his life task has the
nature and quality of a religious
service and that if he meditates about
the symbolic meaning of the images in
his soul they will lead him to this
realization in this dream the anima
appears in her proper positive role that
is as a mediator between the ego and the
self the four times for a configuration
of the pictures points to the fact that
the celebration of this inner Mass is
performed in the service of totality as
Jung has demonstrated the nucleus of the
psyche the self normally expresses
itself in some kind of fourfold
structure the number four is also
connected with the anima because as Jung
noted there are four stages in its
development the first stage is best
symbolized by the figure of Eve which
represents purely instinctual and
biological relations the second can be
seen in Faust Helen she personifies a
romantic and aesthetic level that is
however it's still characterized by
sexual elements the third is represented
for instance by the Virgin Mary a figure
who raises love arrows to the heights of
spiritual devotion the fourth type is
symbolized by Sapientia wisdom
transcending even the most holy and the
most pure of this another symbol is the
Shulamite in the Song of Solomon in the
psychic development of modern man this
stage is rarely reached the Mona Lisa
comes nearest to such a wisdom anima at
this stage I am only pointing out that
the concept of fourfold nurse frequently
occurs in certain types of symbolic
material the essential aspects of this
will be discussed later but what does
the role of the anima as guide to the
inner world mean in practical terms this
positive function occurs when a man
takes seriously the feelings moods
expectations and fantasies sent by his
anima and when he fixes them in some
form
for example in writing painting
sculpture musical composition or dancing
when he works at this patiently and
slowly other more deeply unconscious
material Wells up from the depths and
connects with the earlier material after
a fantasy has been fixed in some
specific form it must be examined both
intellectually and ethically with an
evaluating feeling reaction and it is
essential to regard it as being
absolutely real there must be no lurking
doubt that this is only a fantasy if
this is practiced with devotion over a
long period the process of individuation
gradually becomes the single reality and
can unfold in its true form many
examples from literature show the anima
as a guide and mediator to the inner
world
Francesco colonna's hip neuro tamekia
rider Haggard's she or the eternal
feminine in goethe's faust in a medieval
mystical text an anima figure explains
her own nature as follows I am the
flower of the field and the lily of the
valleys I am the mother of fair love and
of fear and of knowledge and of holy
hope I am the mediator of the elements
making one to agree with another that
which is warm I make cold and the
reverse and that which is dry I make
moist and the rivers and that which is
hard i soften I am the law in the priest
and the word in the prophet and the
council and the wise I will kill and I
will make to live and there is none that
can deliver out of my hand in the Middle
Ages there took place of perceptible
spiritual differentiation in religious
poetical and other cultural matters and
the fantasy world of the unconscious was
recognized more clearly than before
during this period the Knightly cult of
the lady signified an attempt to
differentiate the feminine side of man's
nature in regard to the outer woman as
well as in relation to the inner world
the lady to whose service the knight
pledged himself and for whom he
performed his heroic deeds was naturally
a personification of the anima the name
of the carrier of the Grail in vote from
profession box version of the
is especially significant come to your
guide in love matters she taught the
hero to differentiate both his feelings
and his behavior toward women later
however this individual and personal
effort of developing the relationship
with the anima was abandoned when her
sublime aspect fused with the figure of
the virgin who then became the object of
boundless devotion and praise when the
anima as virgin was conceived as being
all positive her negative aspects found
expression in the belief in witches in
China the figure parallel to that of
Mary is the goddess Quan Yin a more
popular Chinese anima figure is the Lady
of the moon who bestows the gift of
poetry or music on her favorites and can
even give them immortality in India the
same archetype is represented by Shakti
Parvati bratty and many others among the
Moslems
she is chiefly Fatima the daughter of
Muhammad worship of the anima as an
officially recognized religious figure
brings the serious disadvantage that she
loses her individual aspects on the
other hand if she is regarded as an
exclusively personal being there is the
danger that if she is projected into the
outer world it is only there that she
can be found this latter state of
affairs can create endless trouble
because man becomes either the victim of
his erotic fantasies or compulsively
dependent on one actual woman only the
painful but essentially simple decision
to take one's fantasies and feelings
seriously can at this stage prevent a
complete stagnation of the inner process
of individuation because only in this
way can a man discover what this figure
means as an inner reality thus the anima
becomes again what she originally was
the woman within who conveys the vital
messages of the self